Guten Tag. Ich bin Krimaz und hier Ersten.
Ich werde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid, wenn etwas unklar ist. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Tim Schröder.
Könnten Sie bitte Vorname und Nachname bestabieren?
Der Vorname ist Tim, Tim, ein Männername. Und Schröder ist S-T-H-R-O-Umlaut, D-E-R.
Alles klar. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt und bin geboren am 12.03.66.
66. Wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 185 kg und bin jetzt noch 70 kg.
70 kg? Was Sie bescheiden haben im Moment?
Ja, mir geht es vom Bauch her so schlecht seit einer ganzen Weile.
Das kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht von mir.
Ich habe immer wieder Verstopfungen und dann habe ich wieder Durchfall.
Dass meine Verdauung mir solche Probleme macht, das kenne ich eigentlich nicht.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich, seit ja, zunehmend, dass ich auch Bauchschmerzen habe.
Und zwar tut das so, um den Bauchennabel herum ist es ganz schmerzhaft.
Es kramft sich so alles zusammen und was ganz schlimm ist,
es tut richtig stark wie wenn ich Stuhlgang machen muss.
Po, und wenn ich das hinter mir habe, dann bin ich wirklich schweißgebadet
und bin ich richtig, richtig kao.
Ich kriege auch nicht mehr gut Luft und fühle mich total schlapp
und deswegen habe ich, ich muss mich jetzt doch mal darum kümmern.
Seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, also, dass das so schlimm ist, ist vielleicht so seit 3 Wochen.
3 Wochen?
Ja, 2-3 Wochen, es wird immer mehr halt.
Gibt es Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Ich kann das nicht sagen, das hat mir einmal angefangen.
Ich habe gesagt, das ist mir aufgefallen mit dieser komischen,
unregelmäßigen Verdauung und ich habe gesagt, besonders schlimm zu zweit,
wenn ich Stuhlgang machen muss.
Wie oft? Verstoffung und Durchfall?
Na ja, also mal ist 3 Tage lang, dass ich gar nicht auf die Toilette kann
und dann ist mit einmal hintereinander weg 3 Tage,
wo ich das Gefühl habe, ich muss 6 Mal am Tag auf die Toilette.
Könnten Sie bitte beschreiben, die Schutul, zum Beispiel,
Weserige oder Fettreiche Schutul?
Fettreiche, weiß ich, da sind keine Fettaugen drauf,
aber wässrig ist es schon, wenn ich Durchfall habe
und dann so mit Nahrungsresten, dass es halt nicht richtig verdaut ist.
Wie stark die Bauchsmärzen von 1 bis 10,
eines sehr leichtes, eines sehr starkes?
Ja, schwer zu sagen.
Also sehr stark, da sind schon leichtig, also über die Hälfte auf alle Fälle.
Vielleicht so bei 6?
Also weiß ich, das so krampft, und dann kramft es wieder ein bisschen nach
und dann krampft es mit einmal wieder so, ja, ganz übel, ja.
Ich schalte die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nein, ich habe eigentlich das Gefühl, dass das immer so um den Bauchnabel herum ist, ja.
Haben Sie gegen die Schmerzmittel eingenommen?
Nein, das soll man gegen Bauchschmerzen nehmen,
da versucht man mal Pfeffer Münstee zu trinken,
oder, ja, aber mir schmeckt, ja, also leichtes Essen zu essen,
dass man irgendwie nichts Fettiges ist und nichts Herzhaftes,
also ich würde jetzt gerade keine Rotkohl essen
oder irgendwie scharf gewürztes Essen,
aber es schmeckt mir auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht, ja.
Und ja, also ich essen so, ja, mal ein bisschen Kartoffelbrei oder so was,
und da habe ich dann das Gefühl, dass das okay ist, ja,
aber ich würde mich jetzt im Augenblick gar nicht trauen,
so etwas Herzhaftes zu essen.
Gab es in ihr Schutulblut?
Genau, habe ich mir das nicht angeguckt, ich glaube, aber nicht,
ich habe da nichts gesehen.
Leiden Sie unter Erbrochen oder Übelkeit?
Also ja, schlecht ist mir schon manchmal ein bisschen,
aber also ich musste mich nicht übergeben,
Sie meinen, ob ich unter, ob ich mich übergeben habe,
ob ich unter Erbrechen leide.
Ja, nee, das habe ich, nee, das musste ich nicht.
Aber so, ja, so ein bisschen schlecht und schlapp ist mir
und es schmeckt halt irgendwie nicht, also ja.
Nicht schmeckt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, also das nicht,
aber ich habe manchmal schwitzig so ganz doll,
ja, gerade wenn die Schmerzen schlimm sind, schwitzig.
Und auch Nacht habe ich das zurzeit manchmal,
das kenne ich eigentlich sonst gar nicht.
Besonders nach verstehe ich richtig.
Ja, und auch wenn die Schmerzen schlimm sind, ja.
Schmerzen sind, alles klar.
Gib es etwas, die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Wie gesagt, also beim Essen traue ich mich nicht irgendwie,
was Herzhaftes zu essen, denke dann wäre es schlimmer.
Und ja, wenn ich im Bett liege, habe ich manchmal das Gefühl,
dass es schon ein bisschen besser ist.
Aber eigentlich weniger die Schmerzen,
also diese allgemeine Schwäche, das mir jetzt so entgegenkommt.
Hat sich Ihr Hautfarbe verändert?
Verändert. Die Hautfarbe ist mir nicht aufgefallen, also wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Also, meine Frau hat nichts gesagt.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemein-Gesündheit stellen.
Haben Sie Schutelfrost?
Nein, Schutelfrost habe ich nicht.
Nur nach Speis.
Haben Sie in nächstes Zeit Apotheos genommen?
Ja, weil ich eben auch nicht, weil mir das Essen nicht schmeckt.
Ich habe 3 kg abgenommen.
Seit wann haben Sie abgenommen?
3 kg.
Also in den letzten paar Monaten, also seit so 6 Wochen.
6 Wochen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, wenn ich so schwitzen muss, dann wache ich halt auf
und dann schlafe ich nicht mehr so gut.
Und ich kann nicht gut einschlafen vereinigen.
Ich bin so ein bisschen unruhiger.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Schuturl-
Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen habe ich zum Glück keine Probleme.
Alles klar.
Leiden Sie ein krönigener krankmung?
Das ist ein kranker, aber das ist ein Blut-Tor.
Ja, Blut-Tor, das habe ich ein bisschen.
Das habe ich aber schon lange.
Dann nehme ich Walzatan und damit geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Einmorgens?
Kennen Sie die Dosierung, Walzatan?
Nein, kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, was da draufsteht.
Ja, und dann, ja, also, was mir eigentlich schon seit ein paar Jahren Probleme macht,
dass ich, ja, dass ich so saures Aufstoßen habe.
Und da muss ich manchmal, also das nehme ich dann nur,
wenn das gerade unangenehm ist, nehme ich Omoprazol.
Omoprazol?
Wie oft und, weil schon das Südere nehmen Sie Omoprazol?
Ich weiß gar nicht, also ich nehme dann eine Tablette
und wenn es nicht besser wird, nehme ich am Tag noch eine.
Aber also ich mag das vor allen Dingen, wenn ich merke,
dass ich so sauer bin.
Haben Sie jetzt sauer Aufstoßen?
Nein, im Augenblick geht es eigentlich, ja.
Bleiben Sie unter Sodblännen?
Jetzt?
Jetzt im Augenblick nicht, aber das ist manchmal so, wenn ich,
wenn ich, ne, wenn, dann sehe ich auch zu, dass ich das Omoprazol nehme.
Alles klar. Seit wann haben Sie eine Bullethochdruck?
Oh, das hat man vor zehn Jahren festgestellt.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Gibt es andere Vorarl-Kranken?
Ja, ja, wo ich auch ständig eigentlich in Behandlung bin.
Ich habe ziemlich häufig Hämorrhiten.
Und da sind schon jetzt immer wieder mal so kleine Operationen gemacht worden.
Und das war jetzt auch vor, ja, ist jetzt zwei Monate her,
da hat man so eine Bandligatur gemacht.
Bandligatur?
War es Komplikation los, diese Operation?
Ja, das ist ja schon mehrfach gemacht worden.
Das machen sie immer mal wieder, wenn ich dann merke,
dass ich zu sehr Probleme habe.
Okay.
Gibt es noch andere Vorarl-Kranken oder waren Sie in Lässesterstheßchener im Krankenhaus?
Das so näher war ich nicht, nee.
Und sonst, ja, manchmal tut mir die Knie weh
und wenn das zu schlimm wird, dann die Knie.
Ja, wenn ich zu viel gearbeitet habe oder so weiß nicht,
manchmal tun die Gelenke weh
und dann nehme ich so gegen die Schmerzen, Ibuprofen,
aber also auch nicht regelmäßig, auch nicht so oft.
Wie viel Dosierung?
Ach, fast Sie alles wissen wollen.
Ich weiß immer gar nicht, was da draufsteht.
Ich nehme immer nur die Tabletten,
aber ich denke, gibt es 500 oder so?
600, alles klar.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, diese hemorrhidem Geschichten.
Bis auf Hemorrhiden?
Nee, sonst habe ich eigentlich nie eine Operation gehabt.
Alles klar.
Sind Sie vorstandlich?
Ja, ich bin Lehrer und deswegen muss ich natürlich,
habe ich viel Kontakt mit anderen Personen
und ich finde es wichtig, dass wir uns alle gegen Covid impfen.
Ja, super.
Waren Sie in der Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, aber im Ausland war ich nicht mehr.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein,
bis auf Wasser, um eine Prusor.
Und dann, bei Bedarf, aber sonst eigentlich nichts?
Nein, bei Bedarf.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie irgendwie Allergen oder Unfahrt- rlichigkeit?
Ja, also, was ich tatsächlich nicht nehmen darf gegen die Schmerzen,
ist Paracetamol.
Das habe ich irgendwann mal probiert und das hat nicht gut funktioniert.
Da habe ich so einen Ausschlag bekommen und es hat ganz früh war gejuckt.
Ja, das darf ich halt nicht nehmen.
Gibt es noch andere Allergen oder Unfahrt- rlichigkeit?
So viel ich weiß nicht mehr.
Wie lange sind Sie in der Zeit?
Ja, ein Laster muss eine Mensch sein.
Ja, ich rauche ordentlich.
Ich rauche 2 Päckchen am Tag.
2 Päckchen?
Wie lange sind Sie in der Zeit?
Ja, seit ich an dieser Schule bin, da 15 Jahren.
15 Jahre.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, dass das ungesund ist.
Es kostet auch so viel.
Aber trotzdem, wenn man erst mal angefangen hat,
kann man das schwer aufwachen.
Ich färschte.
Wir haben Stress bei der Arbeit.
Da ist immer viel rummel.
Wenn man dann mal zwischendurch eine Pause machen kann.
Ich färschte, dass ihre Situation,
für sie manchmal Stress ist.
Wenn Sie möchten,
kann ich nach dem Unserergeschenk
ein Wohnungsprogramm anbieten.
Ja, können wir mal gucken.
Erst mal will ich jetzt die andere Baustelle haben.
Okay, alles klar.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich trinke abends gerne mein Glas Wein.
Nicht jeden Abend, aber vielleicht 3-4 Mal in der Woche.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich habe noch nicht probiert.
Ich gebe es in Ihrer Familie bestimmte Erkrankungen.
Ich habe es nicht.
Ja, mein Vater hat so Polypen im Darm.
Das hat man mal bei so einer Darm-Spiegelung festgestellt.
Aber sonst, meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund.
Super.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war einzukennend.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, ich habe zwei wachsende Kinder.
Ja, sie sind zum Glück gesund.
Schreiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich fahre oft mit dem Fahrrad zu arbeiten.
Manchmal mache ich auch so ein bisschen mal ein Sport-Arg mit.
Aber ganz exzessiv mache ich das nicht.
Und jetzt, zur Zeit fühle ich mich gar nicht nach Sport.
Alles klar.
Das waren alle meine Fragen.
Jetzt werde ich ein paar Untersuchungen,
zum Beispiel Körperlöhre und Untersuchungen
und Blut abnehmen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse sind, informiere ich,
da sind.
Informiere ich Sie darüber.
Ich habe auch eine Frage,
die ich sehe darüber.
Danach werden wir mit Behandlungen beginnen.
Was könnte das sein,
für eine Behandlung?
Ich vermute, die Darmentzündung
ist sehr wichtig.
Aber wir werden sofort
untersucht.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Vielleicht nach den Untersuchungen,
was da rausgekommen ist,
das würde mich interessieren.
Ich empfehle Sie,
in Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich würde mich auch über die Frage
über die Behandlung beginnen.
Ich würde mich über die Behandlung beginnen.
Ist es möglich,
Diagnose zu finden
und behandeln?
Ja.
Ja, wenn das so ist,
dann muss ich das alles regeln.
Das geht ja.
Ich kann meine Frau Bescheid sagen,
meine Sachen holen oder so. Aber das kriegen wir schon hin. Kein Problem. Warten Sie in Untersuchung
Sie machen. Ja, danke schön. Bis bald. Hat noch jemand weitere Fragen? Darf ich fragen? Hallo? Ja, fragen Sie nur.
Wie lange besteht diese Beschwerden schon? Sie haben seit zwei oder drei Wochen gesagt. Ja. Seit fünf
Wochen Verstopfung und Durchfall und seit drei Wochen werden die Schmerzen mehr.
Kennen Sie diese Beschwerden? Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher? Nein, also ich kenne natürlich
diese Probleme mit den Hämorrhien. Das kenne ich aber, dass ich jetzt solche Schmerzen habe.
Das kenne ich gar nicht. Nein. Ist Ihnen ein Auslöser für diese Beschwerden
aufgefallen? Nein, das kenne ich mit. Das stresst mich immer da. Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass das
Bauchschmerzen auslöst. Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen so. Haben Sie bemerkt, dass diese Beschwerden
ich meine Verstopfung und Durchfallattacke verliehen? Ja, ich habe das versucht mit ja,
was, was ich mild im Essen und so. Aber das hat nicht so richtig funktioniert. Und wenn ich dann,
wenn ich dann wieder so verstopft bin, dann versuche ich dann wieder irgendwelche Sachen zu essen,
die dann so ein bisschen aufquellen und dann esse ich halt mal so abends Trockenflaumen oder so was.
Aber ja, dann geht es wieder ganz fix. Okay, danke schön. Frau Oberstein, ich möchte Ihnen heute
die Patienten vorstellen. Ein neuen Patienten vorstellen. Ja, wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ein Patienten. Herr Schrüder ist 59-jährige Patient. Der sich fegen seit drei Wochen bestehende
krampfartige Postprandial, ganze Abdominalgie und Astralum, bei uns vorstellte,
die Schmerzintensität sind von Sein, Sein, Bayer nummerische Skala. Die Patienten,
die haben klocküber seit drei Tagen Stäatore und Obstpation. Stäatore,
die Vertreiche der Höhe. Okay. Da drei Tage? Ja. Die Fragen nach Pirexie, Melana, MZ,
der Schmerzbedingte in Zomni, innerhalb von drei Kilogramm Gewichtferlust. An für Erkrankungen leidet
die Patient an. Vor zehn Jahren arterialer Hypertonie, dagegen nimmt er Walsartan morgens seit ein Jahr
Reflexkrankheit, dagegen nimmt er Omeprazol einmal täglich. Vor zwei Monaten hemorrhieden,
dagegen Bandligato operiert werden. Also da wurde eine Bandligato durchgeführt vor zwei Monaten.
An der Erkrankung von Parasitamol reagiert auf Parasitamol, die sich durch Exantem und
Pruritus äußert. Seit 15 Jahren, zwei Packungen täglich, 30 Packungen ja. Außer dem trinkt er
zweimal Prüfe, ein Glas Wein, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint. Die Mutter des Patienten ist gesund, der Vater des
Patienten leidet an Darmpolipin. Er ist ein Einzelkind und verheiratet. Süden hat er zwei Erwachsenen
in Betrug. Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten? Ich beobachte den Patienten Hautveränderung.
Was erwarten Sie? Ich erwarte nicht jetzt zum Beispiel, ich beobachte Ecterus oder Spinalus,
Anämie, zum Beispiel. Ich palpiere den Abdomen, loslassen und Abverspannung überprüfen.
Ich höre Darm Geräusche ab. Danach werde ich Abdomen-Zonografie durchführen, um mögliche
kurze Abdomen auszuschließen. Was machen Sie noch im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich werde digitale und vegetale Untersuchungen. Da Patienten hat viele Schultulgangprobleme.
Wie geht es weiter? Was wäre der nächste Schritt?
Ich werde in Labo Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, SRP, ESG und Antihilatrikanin vergeben.
Was machen Sie im Labor noch?
Ich werde auf das Schultul-Test überprüfen.
Auf das?
Auf das Endoskopische.
Das ist das nächste. Aber bei der Stuhl-Untersuchung, was wollen Sie wissen?
Das ist das Hemokultur-Test.
Natürlich.
Gut. Dann geht es weiter. Wie ist die endoskopische Untersuchung?
Zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich Darmspiegelung durchführen und Biopsy entnehmen.
Ja genau.
Ich erwarte in Darmspiegelung Schleimheit, Veränderungen, Willösatrophie.
Gut. Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die Befunde, was Sie daraus bekommen haben.
Auch die Laborwerte sind natürlich interessant.
Meinen Sie, ist der Patient jetzt drauf?
Müssen wir den Stationär aufnehmen?
Sehr gut.
Ich werde den Patienten Stationäraufnahmen so empfehlen, um mögliche richtige Diagnose bestätigen, um Zustand überwachen.
Ja, okay. Gut.
Zu dem werde ich Schmerzadaptierte Therapie verschreiben.
Ja, und da müssen wir erst mal gucken, was jetzt als Ergebnis rauskommt.
Warum der solche Schmerzen hat.
Gut.
Gut. Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über den Patienten. Mit dem Befund entsprechen wir nachher nochmal.
Gut. Liebe Frau Doktor, Sie haben heute ein Problem mit Zahlen.
Zahlen?
Mit Zahlen.
Ja, das war, also, da waren ganz viele durcheinander.
Also, der Patient hat angegeben, er hat Schmerzen, 6 von 10.
Sie sagen 8 von 10.
Ah.
Sie sagen, er hat seit 3 Tagen Verstopfung und Durchfall?
Nee, das beschreibt er ja schon ganz lange, seit 5 Wochen.
Aber ich habe gefragt, Bauchschmerzen 3 Wochen Verstopfung 3 Tage.
Nein, er hat gesagt, diesen Wechsel hat er schon seit 5 Wochen.
Und sie haben dann gefragt, wie oft, oder wie lange die Tage, das dauert, bis er Verstopfung hat und dann wieder Durchfall.
Und da hat er gesagt, ja, mal 3 Tage lang Verstopfung und dann wieder Durchfall.
Also, das ist etwas anderes. Also, 3 Tage lang, aber seit 5 Wochen und ja, keine Ausstrahlung.
Dann haben wir, er hat abdominal Schmerzen. Aber eigentlich hat er sehr konkret etwas anderes angegeben.
Er hat gesagt, um den Bauchnabel herum.
Äthiogastische.
Nein, Paranombolecal.
Paranombolecal, okay.
Ja. Das wäre, glaube ich schon, und kolligartige Schmerzen beschreibt.
So, das habe ich da auch, ich kann meine eigene Schrift nicht lesen.
Ach, das war das. Ja, dann haben die sich ein bisschen schwer getan bei der Formulierung mit der Schmerzkala.
Das habe ich nur verstanden, weil ich nicht so, was sie sagen würden. Also.
Wenn sie möchten, sage ich wieder.
Ja, also, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala, wenn von 1 bis 10.
Wenn von 1 sehr leichte Schmerzen sind und sie sehr stark gepasst unerträgt Schmerzen sind.
Das ist ja immer die Formulierung.
Okay.
Gut, dann, ja, dann haben sie gesagt, er reagiert allergisch auf Paracetamol, die sich äußert in...
Exantempoloretisch aus.
Aber er hat eine Allergie auf Paracetamol, die äußert sich dadurch.
Aber wenn er allergisch reagiert, dann kann man sagen, er reagiert allergisch auf Paracetamol.
Mit Voltaus und Arthé.
Aber allergisch aufreagieren, die sich äußert in...
Das ist auch ein Nomen, der geht, die sich äußert in Grammatikalisch einfach nicht richtig.
Ja, ich sehe mal.
Haben wir einmal die Geschichte gehabt, auch ein Klassiker wird von mir immer wieder gerne reklamiert.
Er hat vor 10 Jahren Bluthochdruck gehabt.
Das wäre ja schön, wenn der Bluthochdruck einmal da ist und dann nicht mehr.
Er hat seit 10 Jahren Bluthochdruck.
Das war anderes.
Ja, 10 Jahre.
Vor 10 Jahren war die Diagnosestellung, Punktereignis.
Habe ich schon mehrfach gemacht.
Und seit 10 Jahren eine Dauern, eine lange Zeit.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Richtig gemacht haben sie das grundsätzlich bei der Reflexkrankheit.
Allerdings haben sie da auch die Zahlen wieder verdreht.
Er hat gesagt, er hat das seit 5 Jahren und sie haben daraus ein Jahr gemacht.
Ja, ich verstehe ein Jahr.
Ja, sie haben ein bisschen geknobelt mit den Zahlen heute.
Genauso war das seit 4 Jahren Hämorrhiden.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat 2 Monate.
Nein, ich habe 2 Monate.
Das ist eine alte.
Vor 2 Monaten die letzte OP.
Er hat das aber schon seit 4 Jahren.
Er hatte immer wieder Bandjäger-Touren und zuletzt vor 2 Monaten.
Und er nimmt nicht Ibuprofen 800, wie sie gesagt haben.
Er hat Ibuprofen 600 gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, es ist ein bisschen schwierig mit den Zahlen heute.
Ja, ich verstehe nicht.
Ja, aber dann müssen sie nachfragen, wenn sie nicht richtig verstehen.
Gut.
Beim Anamnese-Gespräch war es eigentlich von den Fragen ganz okay.
Da sind sie logisch nach ihrem Prinzip vorgegangen.
Und haben auch sehr schön aufgepasst, dass sie Sachen weggelassen haben,
die er schon erzählt hat.
Da haben sie nicht nochmal gefragt.
Das fand ich richtig gut.
Im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, wie gesagt, da waren einige Hürden drin.
Einmal sprachlich.
Ich denke schon, dass die Beschreibung der Schmerzen,
als kolikartig und supermulikal,
dass das schon irgendwie wichtig wäre ohne Ausstrahlung,
das ist ja auch coolikartig.
Und ja, das hat er auch angegeben.
Das haben sie, glaube ich, auch nicht weitergegeben.
Im Verlauf von Stuhlgang sind die Schmerzen extrem viel schlechter.
Das hat er gesagt, dann wird es ihm richtig schlecht.
Und er hat Schweißausbrüche, wenn er auf die Toilette muss.
Gut.
Ja, dann.
Das ist mir neulich schon aufgefallen.
Und da habe ich aber nicht dran gedacht, das hinterher zu sagen,
wenn jemand akut mit Bauchschmerzen zu ihnen kommt,
der hat kein nerv, sich von ihnen über Raucherentwöhnung informieren zu lassen.
Raucher sind ziemlich hartlärige Leute.
Der hier ist ja nun auch mit zwei Bäckchen am Tag wirklich sehr heftig dabei.
Und der weiß natürlich auch, dass das ungesund ist.
Das wissen eigentlich alle, die sind ja nicht doof.
Eigentlich wissen alle, dass es ungesund ist.
Trotzdem lassen sie es nicht.
Und ich denke in so einer Akutsituation,
wo ich mit starken Bauchschmerzen und Übelkeit und so komme,
da will ich nicht hören, dass Rauchen ungesund ist
und dass es vielleicht ein Thema ist, an dem man hinterher mal arbeiten kann.
Ich gebe Ihnen material zur Raucherentwöhnung.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, springt er Ihnen ins Gesicht.
Ja, diese Information ist in normalen Leben nicht sehr wichtig,
ins Wohnungsprogramm.
Aber ich denke in Prüfung, warum nicht sagen,
in Wohnungsprogrammen oder reagiert Starke Raucher?
Also ich meine, das kann man nicht komisch hallos runterschlucken, ja?
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht tatsächlich, wie die Prüfer reagieren.
Vielleicht können das irgendwelche Leute mal sagen,
die die Prüfung schon hinter sich haben, die der Erfahrung haben.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Fakt ist, dass das natürlich massiver Nikotin kommt.
Normale Weise, sie haben recht.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwann besonders freundlich reagiert.
Wenn sie ihm, wenn er allerakut ankommt
und allein schon die Frage, wird er ja als Zumutung empfinden.
Und er wird auch, wenn er, also so wie ein normaler Mensch gebacken ist,
wird er wahrscheinlich nicht zugeben, dass er zwei Päckchen am Tag raucht.
Ja?
Die Leute verschweigen das genauso, wie sie ihren Alkoholkonsum nicht real schildern.
Was meinen Sie, wie viel?
Also ich bin immer sehr amüsiert über diese Fallbeispiele hier,
weil die Leute alle so wenig Alkohol trinken.
In Wirklichkeit saufen die Deutschen mal ganz ehrlich.
Die trinken unheimlich viel und richtig harte Sachen.
Und die trinken literweise Bier und die trinken literweise Schnaps.
Und ja, es scheint irgendwie kein Kraut dagegen gewachsen zu sein.
Und aber auch dieser massiven Nikotin-Konsum,
ja, da kann man, oh, das ist aber ziemlich viel, kann man schon sagen.
Sie wissen, dass es nicht gesund ist.
Er hat ja schon abgehoben, er will jetzt nicht überregen.
Aber ich würde ja jetzt nicht ausführlich sagen,
wir können nachher mal über einen Entwünschung sagen.
Ja, ich demäne so.
Ja, gut.
Das waren diese Geschichten.
Jetzt wollte noch irgendjemand uns vielleicht helfen
und sagen, welche Parameter sie noch bestimmen müssen
bei Morbus Grun im Blut.
Kann uns da jemand helfen?
Ja.
sozusagen der Telefonjoker.
Und das muss ich Dr. Lohet.
Dr. Pupel möchte gerne unser Telefonjoker sein.
Der Person, der Sie sich anrufen haben,
hat sie nicht erreichbar sein können.
Ja, da hat sich jemand gedrückt.
So, jetzt gucke ich mal eben schnell, was war das Morbus Grun, ne?
Morbus Grun.
Wie würde ich?
Gastroenterologische Konzil.
Das ist gut, ja.
Das ist dann der Telefonjoker.
Ich gebe dir Entstehung.
Ich rieche hier ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein.
Das ist der Telefonjoker.
Ich habe hier ein Telefonjoker.
Ich rieche hier ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein.
Auto, Immunsystem.
Ja, also Immunsuppression, nee.
Was war die, was war die, genau, Frage, ich glaube.
Die Frage, was man nachweisen kann.
Äh, ja, Äh, Antikörper.
Autoantikörper.
P-Anker?
Ja, P-Anker und äh, Asker.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein.
Das ist ja ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein.
Ja, also fragen Sie mich nicht, ich verschehe nur Bahnung.
Aber das, also das sind diese Sachen, genau.
Also Immunantikörper, Autoimmunantikörper.
Und äh, Schutul, äh, Schutul und das ist in Zawicht
äh, Kalpo Protektin, Laktoferin, äh, Schutulkulturen.
Ah, stimmt, das ist aber für Morbus Kron.
Äh, übrigens, äh, interessiert Sie, was der Patient tatsächlich hatte?
Möchten Sie wissen, was der Patient tatsächlich hatte?
Was die richtige Diagnose war?
Hm, keine.
Möchten Sie es wissen?
Die Vertikulitis?
Nee, es ist kein Kron.
Äh, es ist tatsächlich ein Kolonkarzinom.
Kolonkarzinom.
Kolonkarzinom ist meine Differenzialdiagnose, nicht wahr?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Aber deswegen äh, sage ich, das äh, das ist ja spannend,
dass Sie hatten, Sie hatten praktisch ja bei den Differenzialdiagnosen dabei.
Ja.
Und ja klar, das sind Sachen, die ergeben sich erst in der Diagnostik, ja.
Spätestens natürlich bei der Darmspiegelung, da würde man es dann sehen.
Aber möglicherweise, also, ja, der hat ja schon eine relativ ausgeprägte Bäsung,
Tomatik eigentlich.
Na gut, die kann es bei Kron natürlich auch geben.
Den Leuten geht es ja auch zum Teil...
Ja, der Patient hat viele Bäsentome.
Ja.
In der Patanz, in Somni, Geweferloren.
Schweißausbrüche.
Nichts, die Patroce.
Na, genau.
Also der, äh, das ist tatsächlich ein Patient mit Kolonkarzinom.
Mhm.
Genau.
Gut.
Augenblick, ich guck noch mal, was die Frühe an Fragen gestellt haben.
Äh, ich, äh, Entschuldigung.
Ja.
Äh, meine Pardagdiagnose, äh, für diesen, äh, für diesen Patienten, äh, war, äh, Reistarmsyndrom.
Aber äh, natürlich, äh, er habe Schwitzen.
Mhm.
Äh, äh, er hat gesagt, mein, äh, Geschmick ist anders.
Äh, dann, vielleicht, äh, kann man verstehen, 3 Kilo abgenommen.
Aber, ja.
Mhm.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Also Reistarmsyndrom wäre tatsächlich auch noch eine Differenzialdiagnose gewesen.
Mhm.
Ja.
Und jetzt habe ich aber Ihre Frage ehrlich gesagt nicht verstanden.
Können Sie die Bitte noch einmal wiederholen, Frau Dr. Ippel?
Mhm.
Äh, warum, äh, ich würde fragen, äh, erste Diagnose kann, äh, Verdachtdiagnose kann, äh, Reistarmsyndrom.
Äh.
Also das ist auf alle Fälle mit drin, ja.
Okay.
Mhm.
Ja.
Aber, äh, er habe äh, äh, äh, Gewicht verlogen.
Dann, äh, Schwitzing, das ist B-Alarm.
Mhm.
Äh, und natürlich, äh, Rauchen, Risikofaktion.
Genau.
Denken wir, okay.
Mhm.
Kolonkarsnom auch.
Okay.
Mhm.
Jo.